[Music]
hi everyone my name is brittany thanks
for joining us for another episode of i
got a question
today's question is i stopped watching
mainstream media now what this question
brought me back to my own personal
journey in life when social media was
newer at least among my peers
when i was younger social media overtook
my life it affected my homework my sleep
even my eyesight i would be on it at
church and it ultimately
negatively affected my relationship with
god it became toxic and all-consuming it
was the most important thing in my life
and so i remember sitting down one day
and thinking to myself if god were to
read back to me the story of my life
what would that look like
all i could imagine was him reading back
to me where i spent endless hours upon
hours glued to my phone scrolling all
day long
so i felt convicted and made a decision
to quit cold turkey i told myself i am
going to stop using social media for a
whole month
well
it didn't go as smoothly as i thought it
would
it was agonizing i didn't know what to
do with myself i can't tell you how many
times i picked up my phone on the first
day out of habit
so
unfortunately i failed
i don't even think i made it past the
first two hours it wasn't until later i
realized i wasn't really setting myself
up for the win stopping a toxic habit is
only one part of the problem
here was my downfall i focused so much
on what i was leaving behind instead of
focusing on what there was to look
forward to
this led me to a verse that i've always
cherished isaiah 43 19 which says see i
am doing a new thing
now it springs up do you not perceive it
i am making a way in the wilderness and
streams in the wasteland
i love this verse because it sheds light
on how much god knows us we are prone to
thinking that the past will never amount
to what the future holds but god is
telling us i'm doing something new
it's just on the horizon keep looking
ahead keep striving and keep pushing you
are almost there
and so if you're struggling with letting
media go here's my advice
number one
give yourself things to look forward to
pray about it and ask god to show you
more beneficial ways to fill up your
time
make a list of the things you've always
wanted to do or used to love to do but
haven't had the time for maybe finally
getting to that book you always wanted
to read maybe getting back to that
beloved hobby that you suddenly lost
time for maybe rekindling distant
relationships or visiting nature parks
literally make a list of all the things
you have to look forward to and focus on
that create a plan and set yourself up
for a win my second piece of advice
would be to be patient with yourself the
thing about bad habits is that they are
hard to break i think because in a way
it becomes so rooted in our identity
that when we part from it it's kind of
like rediscovering who we are
so be patient with yourself
offer yourself some grace and take it
one day at a time
to be honest it took me five years to
finally get to a point where i could
stay off social media for weeks at a
time
i once wasn't able to go two hours now i
can almost go two months without feeling
like i'm missing out on anything
so never underestimate the power of just
putting one foot in front of the other
hey guys thanks for watching if you have
any questions please feel free to reach
out to us on social media or
on our website we are always looking
forward to reading your questions and
answering them for you so until next
time
[Music]
do
you